okay so I've got my car my police car
sorry and I've got it at its
intersection
sorry going towards that intersection
now I'm interested in the other car okay
and at the beginning I put the other car
here because that's where the question
tells me it is right however I hope
you've realized by now at that point
it's sort of like a meaningless will not
mean this but not a very useful diagram
okay because the actual situation I'm
interested in is after the car is nicked
off it's gone way past the intersection
so I'm gonna draw the second car up here
anyways any wheels okay and the angle
I'm interested in that feet up it still
looks relatively similar to what it was
before okay there's my fear right now
here's the crucial difference okay
instead of calling this X and this wine
I hope you see that's where the problem
started creeping in and in a lot of
questions you've got right you don't
have any choice as to you've got to have
two variables but then you've got to get
them in relation to each other right
except that problem here was the x and y
independent because X has its own rate
of change and Y has its own engine
arrange a trajectory so instead of
introduced in x and y I want to call
these two distances something else that
have just one variable in common okay so
what are these distances I'm gonna call
these distances variables based on time
because I have to deal with time right
I've got deep theater on DT that's what
I'm trying to find okay so therefore and
we know these two sides their lengths
depend on time right so how can i
express that well let's think about this
car okay at time 0 which is where the
question began okay where is the car
it's at the intersection at time 0 after
time 1 where will the car be it'll be 60
feet away
at time to where will the car be 120
feet away and if we want the to at time
3 to be a hundred and eighty feet away
right and 240 and so on so if I want to
express this distance the second car as
a function of time what is it well as
time progresses every time he goes
further away it's gonna be 60 feet times
the time so I'm gonna call that distance
60 10 iqc this is gonna be a better way
to do things because I have to do it see
anyway right so I've avoided this second
variable Y okay all right by the same
logic
what will this distance be well at time
zero when the question begins how far is
the police car from the intersection
it's 200 feet right 200 feet and then as
time progresses he gets closer right so
after one second he will be 120 feet
away and then another second here will
be 40 feet and then so on right so it's
minus KDT you see that so built into
these equations you can see D if we call
this Y dy DT is 60 isn't it that's the
same rent we had before and here if we
call this X DX on DT would still be
minus 80 so we've got the same kind of
information on you but just in a way
whichever way is having more variables
okay
more variables equals more more bad so
don't do it
okay oh boy where you can all right so
now that I've got this I can start so I
can actually go directly here I don't
even need to talk about chainable that's
a bit different isn't it I sort of built
chain rule into these without having X's
or wise because now I can work out the
relationship between theta and T
directly by angle
opposite adjacent right angle triangle
okay so what's the relationship between
theta and T well I guess the ratio I
want is tan okay so that's going to be
let's see here
op is no damage a since that's 60 T on
two hundred minus 80 T okay so I've got
a common factor of 20 so I'll take that
out okay so there's my tan theta but of
course if I want to differentiate I need
it just in terms of theta okay and then
I can work out defeated it to you
directly so I just slap a tan Universal
on the other side okay happy so far so
now I can dig straight into defeat on
the team no X's and Y's okay so if I
differentiate this and because it's
quite a tricky question I'm actually
going to go ahead and do them you know
let u equal this and do the substitution
and just so I can work out what it is so
I'm gonna say before I get to defeat on
the tape I'm gonna say let u equal three
T on 10 plus 14 that implies that D u1
DT is question rule kind of weighted yet
you see I'm gonna get V times u - which
is just three minus u v - which is minus
4 all over V squared ok so you can see
why I was worth doing the substitution
because I do not want to do this in my
game okay I'm gonna get 30 minus 12t
there and then conveniently I've got
plus 12t here
okay so my teas are gonna cancel here's
my D you on DT DT now that's what I let
u equal therefore my function of the
theta is theta equals tan inverse of U
so what's the theater do you do you
remember this is little without a square
root in it okay so this is 1 over 1 plus
u squared ok so I ended up having to do
chain rule anyway but not because of
different variables per se but because
it was a messy kind of function okay so
what I was really after was the feed
upon DT which is his my chain rule okay
so here because I don't actually want
use at all I'm gonna get rid of my units
of it back for what I had before okay so
this is gonna be 1 over 1 plus
that's my defeat on to you she is my GU
on DT okay and here it is actually in
our interests who I multiply this out
because it'll make this denominator
simpler yeah in our fraction about 30 on
the top
you're happy with that that okay yeah
alright now I suppose I could simplify
it a little further because there's
going to be some like terms that can
combine here but I think at this point
it's simple enough for me to actually
start to solve a question because I was
interested in a particular point in time
namely when T is equal to two okay
by the way before I go ahead and work
this out you just have a look at your
result here for d theta/dt it doesn't
make sense it's positive yes
so therefore the angle is increasing
over time does that match what you would
expect it does right because as that car
races off and as this one gets closer
and closer closer at the intersection
this train was going to get sort of
thinner and thinner and thinner so this
angle theta is increasing okay all right
so now I can sub you okay so I've got D
theta DT which is equal to 30 over okay
what do we got 10 minus 8 all squared
plus 9 times 4 that's 30 over 4 plus 36
that looks like 30 on 40 which is 3/4
and of course our units is today go so
it's radians per second okay and you
okay
exhale now this is not particularly
pleasant partly because what we got for
theta and T was not nice so we had to be
careful with our chain rule here but it
is better than bashing your head against
the brick wall and trying to work with
your X's and Y's which eventually there
are ways to work with but it'll be 5
times longer